sí
escándalo real virginia sufre demandó al
príncipe andrés en la corte federal de
manhattan en nueva york por abuso sexual
y así reaccionaron algunos ingleses
y no sólo porque es tu sabes que la
realeza no significa que tengas que
salirse con la suya básicamente
cualquier otro miembro público no le
alegraría y no sería justo que el fin
working show hoy serguéi exenta se manda
una señal al resto del mundo de que no
importa la posición en la que estés si
estás en una posición de poder o
autoridad o eres una persona con
influencia no te puedes comportar de una
manera inaceptable y las mujeres deben
ser tratadas con respeto respect you
free asegura que el hijo de la reina
isabel la forzó a tener relaciones
sexuales en tres ocasiones cuando tenía
17 años y aunque el príncipe aún no se
ha pronunciado en 2019 negó conocerla
desde entonces se apartó de la vida
pública la demandante se escoltó en la
ley de víctimas menores de nueva york la
cual establece que la conducta sexual
contra un niño tiene un plazo de
prescripción de cinco años
este es un caso que podría durar 20 o 30
años a través de los distintos niveles
de apelación en cada uno de los puntos
del camino así que no creo que este caso
sea un caso que se presentará ante el
sistema judicial en un corto plazo
la supuesta víctima también ha
manifestado en varias ocasiones que
jeffrey epstein los presentó y que el
príncipe estaba al tanto de su red de
tráfico sexual y aunque andrés desmintió
las acusaciones
reconoció haberse hospedado en las
residencias de epstein quien apareció
muerto mientras cumplir una condena en
eeuu por abuso sexual